il ya près de 30 ans que la peine de
mort a été abolie en france mais il faut
savoir qu'elle est toujours en vigueur
dans 20% des pays de la planète
notamment au japon et dans certains
états américains à genève se tient en ce
moment un congrès contre la peine de
mort des militants tentent de convaincre
en s'appuyant sur des témoignages de
prisonniers qui ont parfois passer des
dizaines d'années en prison avant d'être
innocenté d'autres attendent leur
exécution portraits croisés signé
virginie fichés et eric chacun image
simple d'un bonheur ordinaire qu'il y a
trois ans encore
curtis mccarty nozette imaginer
emprisonné en 1986 il a passé près de 20
ans dans le couloir de la mort d'une
prison de l'oklahoma avant que son
innocence soit enfin reconnu la moitié
de sa vie en suspens chaque jour c'était
une bataille d'essayer de traverser la
journée sans perdre la raison
en essayant de faire avec la souffrance
autour de nous en voyant ces hommes
s'effondrait moralement physiquement
à force d'attendre une attente
insupportable aussi pour sandrine
skinner militante abolitionniste
elle correspondait avec hank un détenu
américain condamné à mort pour un triple
meurtre qu'elle a finalement épousé
malgré l'épreuve le disculpant son
exécution vont simplement d'être reporté
une fois de plus moi j'ai besoin qu'il
n'y croit pour me battre avec lui ça me
perturbe
ça me perturbe que lui se disent que
c'est fini quoi qui s'en sortira pas
alors qu'il s'est battu mais bec et
ongles depuis 15 ans avec une force
aujourd'hui la justice texane refuse les
tests adn que réclame
hank skinner une démonstration flagrante
pour sandrine des dysfonctionnements et
de l'obstination de la machine
judiciaire américaine qui préfère courir
le risque de condamner à mort des
innocents est exceptionnel c'est pas
leur condamnation à mort alors qu'ils
étaient innocents qui est exceptionnel
ce qui est exceptionnel c'est qu'il soit
vivant aujourd'hui parce que la norme
c'est ça c'est des procès expéditifs à
charge uniquement avec des avocats
commis d'office qui connaissent très mal
leur travail pour pas dire pas du tout
et un accusé qui n'a pas de moyens fini
en couloir de la mort ceux qui sont
riches ne vont jamais dans le couloir de
la mort depuis la reprise des exécutions
au texas en 77
450 condamnés ont été exécutés parmi eux
130 ont depuis été innocenté ils n'ont
malheureusement pas eu la chance et la
force de curtis mccarty
lorsque je suis arrivé la première fois
là bas j'étais encore assez bien
j'essaie encore de donner un sens à ce
qui arrivait j'ai pris la résolution que
je garderai toujours l'espoir de rentrer
chez moi il ne faut jamais jamais
abandonné parce que on l'a vu dans de
nombreux cas à la toute dernière minute
il se passe des choses encore donc sans
désespérer ni espéré je tiendrai bon
jusqu'au bout et au delà même si son
mari devait mourir dans un mois sandrine
skinner continuera de lutter pour
prouver son innocence continuera de
militer avec curtis et d'autres pour
l'abolition de la peine capitale dans le
monde